[Music]
so
this morning i released a video
had the most views i've ever had is 25
000 views an hour
and take take a while to guess what the
topic is
corona virus yeah it's a very hot topic
right now
you know about i would say 15 years ago
i was doing talks around the
governmental agencies in washington d.c
and also exxon mobil
and they kicked me out they actually
said you can't talk anymore
i called them up and said why they said
well because you're recommending 45 eggs
a day
and that's very bad for the heart i said
no i didn't say 45 i said 4-2-5.
they said oh okay you can come back
so sometimes you have to clarify things
so uh disclosures no financial ties to
pharmaceutical diagnostic or medical
devices
or food industry owner of dr bird.com dr
berg supplements
authored the healthy keto plan i
organized a summit called the healthy
keto summit every year
and my bias is low carb
so today i want to talk about
some unique problems that happen
in the keto uh world i have a large uh
following on social media i have a
facebook
close private group of 300 thousand
people and i'm it's called my keto lab
i'm able to test different things to see
what works
see what problems that people are
running into and uh
gain a tremendous amount of
understanding about what people are
running into and what the solutions are
so i want to share today some common
problems
and solutions one of the biggest ones
being
plateau it's keto stall
so i want to talk about that first
so a couple couple things one is that
you have people who say well it's not
working
i only lost two pounds the first week i
lost six and now i just lost two pounds
i'm like well you have to understand
that is normal
so it takes a little bit of education at
first to set people up
but there's there's different levels of
awareness that you have to
understand you have awareness of the
problem awareness of the cause of the
problem awareness of the solution
and also of the correct solution so
like i would take like men for example
they might have this huge belly but
they're not very aware
that that is a fatty liver they're
they're just like oh yeah it's fine i
can deal with it
so i wouldn't necessarily go right into
teaching them about what to eat
because that's too high level so i
really address
people where they're at and then build
them up
and one of the things i found is that
you have to teach them the basics of
certain things
uh especially like one guy came in he
goes um
yeah your program's not working i tried
it for two weeks and it didn't work
well it did work but then it stopped
working well what did you do well i
stopped
stop the diet i said did you think it
was going to keep working if you stop
so you really have to educate people
from the very beginning
and so there's a really important very
vital principle that i talk about
and that is about it's not lose weight
to get healthy it's get healthy to
lose the weight and this is so
basic because looking at
diabetes as a disease doesn't work as
this being this is like this cause of
cause situation it's the effect of
course of high insulin
if someone does not understand this
concept they're very susceptible to
doing the wrong
solution very unhealthy programs
diet appetite suppressants low quality
products they try to get they try to
actually
diet to lose weight how many of you
agree that dieting actually destroys
your metabolism
you take someone who's menopause and you
ask them
how many diets have you been on it's
probably been 10 or 12 and every time
they do it
of course they're doing it wrong it
slows down the metabolism so
just because someone's losing weight
doesn't mean they're getting healthy
it really depends on how they're losing
weight
so there's some products that people
think are healthy
you have you know of course the slim
fast hidden sugars
if you take a look at the ingredients
high levels of soy protein isolates
which are exposed to hexane
which in pubmed is a neurotoxin and
there's no
fda has no sealing of how much hexane is
in there
had a lot of clients come in that have
done like programs like ideal protein
that
really high in soy protein isolates and
end up with
liver and gallbladder issues so
and they're hidden sugars as well so is
a really important
question that i always always ask people
to figure things out and i think it's
just
it's not emphasized and that is okay
when did this problem
start and what happened just before that
and you can get so much data
i had one lady came in with a heart
attack a heart attack symptoms she's
been to the hospital spent forty
thousand dollars
worth of testing and nothing showed up
and then we find out i said when did you
start
well two weeks ago what day tuesday what
did you eat
she was oh a big banana split i said
okay
laid it on my table started doing some
work on her
and it was basically just a congested
gallbladder
backed up in the liver causing heart
pain all the all the
heart symptoms went away so it's really
really important to find out
what occurred just before you started
having that problem i asked that
question a lot
maltodextrin glycemic index way higher
than
glucose and sugar
so obesity is a symptom
it's not if you focus on obesity you're
going to basically
you're not going to be as successful
it's coming from too much insulin
so i have people focus on other
indicators of health i try to get them
off the weight loss at first because
they may not lose weight initially
especially if they have a slow
metabolism so
i always ask them how is your energy is
your hunger going away that's a good
indication that the insulin is
coming back in a good range
carb cravings if you still have carb
cravings there's still there's a problem
with your blood sugars
is your belly shrinking um
there are people women that are actually
menopausal that have a lot of
atrophy and it looks just like fat
identical because what happens after
menopause is sometimes you have a spike
in cortisol
cortisol tends to turn muscle protein
into glucose
and then it raises insulin so you have
this loss of muscle
looks like cellulite and fat and they're
really adamantly want to lose weight but
this takes
some time to heal this process so in the
process they're building up their
proteins
you know it takes months and months
maybe even a year or two
to build up this protein back there
where actually they're
per volume the muscle is heavier than
the fat so
everything is shrinking they're not
losing weight you just have to teach
them that this is
normal they have to know that so they're
not setting
themselves up for a loss so
the most important thing that a person
could do to increase their health
is to use their own fat as fuel
so there's several advantages of doing
this number one now you start running on
ketones
and there's a lot of advantage it's a
superior fuel more energy output
appetite suppressant more efficient
better lipid profiles
tumors can't consume ketones reduce
oxidative stress
and more o2 less co2 and then you have
the benefits of
reduction of insulin which is the common
denominator
of so many health problems i mean
inflammatory conditions
heart of course diabetes the fatty liver
high cholesterol aneurysms stroke
dementia
other than that it doesn't have any
effects but it's actually pretty
connected to everything so you get to do
these two things
there's a you know about the glycemic
index there's actually an
insulin index too how many of you have
not familiar with the insulin index
okay those are that's a scale
that um it's all the non-carbohydrate
triggers or the non-carbohydrate
influences on insulin
and of course fat is the lowest effect
on insulin
but lean low low-fat protein
like whey protein is very high on the
scale
of the insulin index and this is why
the keto works really good because you
have higher fat higher fat if you have a
whole egg for example versus the egg
whites you have a much less insulin
spike
and this is important just understanding
um what we're trying to do we're trying
to
create as much health benefit by the
reduction of insulin
and so you have the lowering of carb we
don't want to be afraid of fat
and we need to understand that scale but
we also want to look at other ways of
decreasing insulin and one of the
biggest ways is
fasting intermittent fasting um fasting
is
not low carb it's no carb and uh
what happens there's a little hormone
called the gip hormone in the small
intestine
that gets activated every time you eat
no matter what you eat
so if you don't understand that you may
not
put emphasis on fasting and realize that
that's really important especially in
the
helping people with really resistant
weight problems
and that's very beneficial so the
combination of both of these are
vitally important insulin is a
dominating hormone
in the presence of too much insulin a
lot of the other hormones are suppressed
especially growth hormone
insulin-like growth factor
and then you get uh when you consult
people you get this thing where um
uh you find out they're on sorta keto uh
how many of you ever had clients that
are in sort of keto
yeah i'm not losing weight
well what are you doing well on sort of
keto well keto is like
you can't be in sorta keto i mean it
just doesn't work it's like a switch
there's gonna be a point where you're
you're not gonna get into ketosis
there's a certain amount of
carbohydrates that you need to go below
and if your metabolism is low it has to
be even lower
so i know this might be hard to believe
but
some of your your patients or clients
do cheat occasionally and they don't
tell you that they cheat
they keep it a little secret how many
have ever had that happen
once once before so
what happens is they keep a little
secret and they do it again and
again you're coaching them and you go
they're not getting results what's
interesting about this is they tend to
be a bit um
critical to kind of justify it and so i
have learned in practice i have an
advantage of being a practice for 29
years i
work with so many people that um i see
this common scenario that happens
if a client comes in that's not
progressing and they're critical
like they'll say well you know i really
don't like the color of your walls and
and your secretary is just so rude and
i'm not losing weight and i go
thank you very much i have a question is
there anything that you're eating
that you shouldn't be eating i look them
right in the eye and they'll look
they'll do this like
no they look down you know right there
they're not telling the truth so i don't
make them feel guilty says well what do
you think about when they ask you that
question they go
well i did have a little ice cream but
it was organic you know
i said okay good anything else uh potato
chips
but i didn't have that many i got okay
how many do you have well i did have a
bag okay
and i just keep going anything else and
you will be shocked to find out
these guys are consuming massive amounts
of junk food on the side
found out this one lady she's doing
literally i think a whole
bag of oreo cookies every single day
so it's very important if you're
coaching someone to know that
because if you don't know that you're
going to be uh trying something else and
they're going to eventually leave and
you're going to be chop living
so it's i spend a lot of time just
keeping that communication line open so
there's no
secrets i don't care if they cheat just
tell me i want that
communication line open
so for those people that have a very
slow metabolism
and i know you have some clients that no
matter what you do
they just can't nothing works okay let's
put you in a 500
calorie diet still doesn't work have you
exercised more it doesn't work
strict keto it doesn't work you ever
have a client like that
yeah they're usually menopausal they
usually have the thyroid removed
the gallbladder removed they're
pre-diabetic and they have a history of
many different diets
and now they end up in your office and
you're like okay what do i got to do
with this
so what i will do is i'll i'll do all
the things i told you then i'll start to
go down the list and
start to really beef up no pun intended
the intermittent fasting
so i will decrease the frequency of
eating and i'll have them fast longer
there's a really important
rule that i tell my clients and also
even the videos right now
is that don't eat if you're not hungry
do not eat if you're not
hungry because then you're going to be
hungry when you eat because it
stimulates insulin so then the blood
sugar comes down
so it's so simple and so these
individuals
what happens is they're they're going a
long period of time and i told them they
have
two meals a day i said are you hungry
now i just eat them because you told me
i said okay
let's go to one meal a day all right and
i'll do that
are they progressing sometimes they're
not they're not really um
seeing the um the changes that they
really need
and they have maybe a huge belly and you
just have to come up with something
that's a little more powerful
so i will um i'll do this kind of a
stair step method the first thing is
i'll take their uh
their um breakfast and i'll say listen
if you're in the morning if you're not
hungry just don't skip it and start
pushing it forward to lunch
and so pretty pretty much there the
lunch the breakfast is gone
and so they have lunch and dinner and
then what i'll do is i'll take the lunch
and the dinner and i'll start squeezing
them together and
until the point where it's like a
four-hour window
most people do very very well with this
and i do have
quite a few people doing this on my lab
with tremendous amounts of
success some people need to do
one meal a day the key is making sure
they have enough nutrients
in that meal you know to prevent things
like hair loss which i will cover
now some some people need to go even a
little bit longer
not everyone but i have put people that
fast to the point where they're eating
once every other day
now as long as your energy is good
they're taking the nutrients
and you'll see that they'll finally
start to change and i have
had a handful of people who were
consuming one meal every other day
make sure they do the sea salts and
electrolytes and they finally after all
this time
start losing weight so their metabolism
is so efficient that
this is what they need and it's not that
they're starving when they're not eating
they're just they're
basically eating their own fat when
they're not eating and that's the
concept that you have to
get across is that you are eating when
you're not eating you're just eating
your fat
so sleeping
interesting had a lady who um
she lifted three and a half million
pounds at the gym over course of a year
and lost
one single pound
and she came in very depressed and i
found out
she was not sleeping she was actually on
the right
she was eating pretty good but she was
she wasn't sleeping
so um i i actually worked with with
sleeping i actually
told her to stop watching the news right
before bed that was the big problem
um i told her to start taking calcium
magnesium
i did some work on her and she started
sleeping like a baby and that was the
only time that things started to kick in
she lost a lot of weight
great before and after i mean don't
underwrite sleep like
my wife and i went on a trip uh recently
because we were like completely
pale and white in january so we went to
the bahamas
to this little remote little island
where they have like
no internet no reception and it got dark
around
6 30. there was nothing to do so we went
to bed at 7 00
and i said well let's just go to bed we
go to bed
i s we think we slept for 13 or 14 hours
i've never felt that better in my life
it was amazing
so i mean i've been running on maybe six
hours if that
just getting more sleep can create huge
changes
in your in your blood sugars in your
body so i need to do more of that
okay stress yes that can affect you i
think out of all the stress
people have a lot of the stress comes
from other people
how many realize that people can stress
people out
certain personality types you got the
slow drivers that just
really jack up my adrenals they're just
driving
and then you have the antagonistic
people but really the
the worst case is the is the passive
aggressive
the underminers they're the person they
told you they stood up for you but they
actually ruin your reputation
they'll say comments like well you've
done quite well for your educational
level
what had this attorney come in to see me
he said
i said hey how did you find out about me
he says well out of all the quacks you
seem to be the less weird
it was kind of a hint of a compliment
but
it's really kind of just taking my wind
out so as a as a practitioner
you're always going to get a percentage
of those people that come in that
are just you don't feel good when
they're around them i screen those out
right now i screen those guys out and
they constantly are
nullifying your results if they get
results there will be someone else that
worked on them wasn't you or they'll say
comments like hey that's a nice sweater
was that on sale
like oh you got a haircut was that cheap
cuts and like
so it's just something about them you
don't really like but i do have a way of
i finally figured out a way of getting
back at these people
revenge you want to know how i do it
you can do but how many of you have
clients like this
yeah this is what you do it's it's a
great great thing
you when they start doing that all you
do is you just look them right in the on
the face look them
really close and just say what what's
that has that been growing
has that been growing you should
probably get that checked out yeah get
your liver checked out
because that's what they're doing to you
they're introverting you
you just flip it they'll be in the
bathroom for hours looking at that
little
back there and like oh my gosh is that
the coronavirus
and then just get them out of your space
and
but with this attorney that came in uh
what i did is i said um
i knew i did not want to take him on so
i said i tell you what this is what i
want to do go up to the front
and i have a bottle of calcium it's four
dollars i want you to buy that
go ahead and try that if it doesn't work
i can't help you never saw him again
so nice way of getting rid of those guys
but stress is a really really key thing
to
oh my gosh exercise either over
exercising over training
or not exercising at all so
regular consistent exercise
um creates some really nice effects with
a lot of things autophagy the cleaning
up of old damaged tissue
protects your immune system keeps your
body full of oxygen
but i had one lady who came in she was
uh exercising i'm not kidding six hours
a day
and no weight loss six hours a day at
the gym
so she was over training so i had her
which took a long time to do this but i
got her to exercise um
like for an hour twice a week and she
started to lose the weight and it was
really a weird brain strain because she
didn't
realize that overture i mean the benefit
of exercise occurs
when you're sleeping the 48 hours later
not during the exercise
exercise is a stress the benefits are
delayed she didn't understand that
um okay bloating so you you
i do recommend vegetables for most
people but if they start bloating i take
them off of it because they might have
sibo
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
they might not deal with them
and so there's been a handful of people
not the majority
that would just can't do well on
vegetables so i will adjust what i do
but i do i'll tell you why i recommend
more vegetables
in a bit but if they're bloating that
can cut down
on the weight loss because they're
they're fluid retained they're just
holding
the stress in the gut and that's
happened a handful of times so you want
to you know just kind of look at that as
well
okay next thing is the transitional
phase when you're getting into ketosis
there's a thing called keto fatigue
has anyone ever experienced that
so i had a chance to just work with a
lot of people and find out this
is mostly potassium deficiency
and when you do keto you're no longer
running in carbs so you're going to dump
a lot of fluid
because carbs retain fluid with that
fluid becomes electrolytes
not just potassium but sodium now our
bodies tend to retain
sodium more than potassium we don't have
um any mechanism to retain potassium
hardly at all so there's this false
information being spread that
spread out there that potassium is
dangerous on our body
if you have well of course if you have
staged kidney disease
yes but if you have healthy kidneys it's
not dangerous in fact potassium is
protective of the kidney if you want
date on that i have
amazing research on that you can you can
ask me later but
but the thing about potassium is out of
all the nutrients we need potassium in
large amounts 4 700 milligrams a day
if you take a look at what you have to
eat to consume that
you're going to find out the majority of
people are just not consuming enough
potassium
so um potassium is involved with a lot
of things fluid
exchange energy it buffers uric acid
it's really an effective thing for blood
pressure
wow it just brings blood pressure down
there's a lot of data on this
also heart rhythm rhythm um
really helps with arrhythmias
because it's involved in the pacemaker
nerve and energy muscle
making hcl but the main purpose of
potassium is involved in the sodium
potassium pump in the cells so you have
these little pumps
on the cell surface that
you have a billion of them let me just
go right to that first
yeah this is what they look like they
have one purpose to keep the
potassium inside the cell and the sodium
outside the cell
to keep this electrical gradient to keep
these two minerals separate
that forms through the help of the
insulated
wall of that cell it helps to form
develop a battery the body allocates
30 of all of its energy to these pumps
and what the what what this energy this
electrical energy does
is it it activates the nerve and the
muscle tissue so
if you're deficient and this pump
doesn't have enough
raw material you're going to get
weakness
and uh in the muscle and things like
that and
so this is one wikipedia so you know
it's true
they said it's the causes of hypokalemia
low potassium
is uh look at the cause one of the
causes is going a ketogenic diet
i don't know if i believe that but i do
know that you'd lose fluid
um with this and so that could be the
reason why
also one of the big symptoms of
hypokalemia the first one is feeling
tired
so if you if you're into exercise and
you're doing endurance exercise
if you take a little more potassium
you're going to find you can go a lot
longer too because your
your cellular pumps have are are
recharged so
to prevent that i i recommend foods that
are high
in um potassium on the ketogenic diet
i don't want to get too much into this
but the potassium and the
the insulated phospholipid layer on the
cell
acts as a capacitor which basically
stores electrical charge
your cells are batteries and
if you divide the amount of voltage
which is uh 150 microvolts inside the
cell by
the thickness of the wall which is very
small it can yield electrical fields in
excess
of 200 kilovolts that's 200 000 volts
so certainly enough to break down any
most insulators so if you compare that
to anything like underground cables
it smokes anything else so your cells
are just
amazing how it can generate this
incredible amount of voltage
and activate muscles and if you make
sure that you give it the right
nutrients
beet tops have the most potassium per
cup
1300 so i mean i don't
consume beet tops so it's uh spinach
the problem with spinach that i have on
the keto is it's high in oxalates
if you're prone to kidney stones i have
them avoid spinach
brussels sprouts 600 something cabbage
300 tomatoes 400 swiss chard
so you can see avocados 830 milligrams
asparagus 400
so typically speaking you're going to
get a little more potassium with greens
um but you can also get them from
lamb you can get potassium from lamb 2
268 for 3 ounces
can of tuna is 280 round steak 3 ounces
of 300
so you really just have to you should
probably uh yourself or with a client
just start calculating how much
potassium is a person really eating
and you may find that it's not even
close
so you may want to substitute with
calcium citrate or another type of
calcium
i'm sorry potassium okay keto flu
is purely a salt deficiency sodium
or chloride no one's really talking
about chloride
salt is composed of 40 sodium 60
chlorides chlorides are really necessary
to make the hydrochloric acid
so it's a very important mineral just as
sodium
so when you do keto you do need more sea
salt
and so that will take care of the flu
flu-like symptoms very quickly and also
weak
muscles here's another gem if you
don't know this this is a no-brainer
you're going to have clients come to you
that have peripheral neuropathy and
there's a really good remedy that seems
to work
the majority of the time because
hyperglycemia
depletes vitamin b1
and b1 is involved in making myelin
sheath
it's it protects the cells against the
complications of high
sugar it's considered a nerve vitamin
when you're low in b1 you get neuritis
you get that excessive thinking thinking
and
like nervous anxiety um i like the best
source of
b1 being nutritional yeast it's more of
a natural type
it rids lactic acid so if you put
someone on metformin
one of the side effects it's rare is
lactic acidosis
b1 reduces that complication
so if you have someone on metformin if
you have on b12 and b1 that would be
very smart
it's involved in four different steps in
the krebs cycle and the mitochondria in
the generation of atp
so it's like the spark plug that occurs
when you have fuel and oxygen coming
into that
krebs cycle and so if you're not if
you've been on a high carb diet you'll
deplete b1
and that's when you start getting the
complications of diabetes and mainly
it's the destruction of the vascular
the capillary function the blood flow to
the nerve
and the eye and the nerve and the also
the epithelial cells in the heart and
the kidney
as well as in the um the peripheral
nerves not to mention the brain
um so ben thought to me if you've never
heard of this it's a fat style will be
one
uh it's a no-brainer it it's quite
miraculous
and they made it fat soluble to
penetrate the myelin sheath in the brain
and it can be absorbed i think it's
seven to nine times more than
waterside will be one but it's a really
um you start
like you just get a bottle of it and
have them take uh you know four
four times a day whatever the
recommended dosage is and uh
it seems to work for peripheral
neuropathies
i will say that some people if it's
really bad it does take months to kick
in
alpha lipoic acid also is good as well
but it reduces the oxidative stress
and the complications of diabetes i have
a lot of references
if you want it hair loss okay
so you have sometimes people say well
keto is very healthy because you're
going to lose all your hair
well that's probably um if you're doing
it incorrectly if you
the the main thing with the hair loss is
you need certain trace minerals
not just for the thyroid um but for
the hair directly so the two trace
minerals that seem to work the majority
of time
are zinc and selenium
and they both are actually involved in
the thyroid
um there's biotin is another really good
one as well if someone has gut issues
it could be the reason why they're not
your body makes biotin so
it could be either that you have you
don't have the friendly bacteria to make
biotin or you have gut damage that
you're not able to absorb that biotin so
sometimes i'll give people biotin in
higher amounts to kick in the hair
but zinc is a really important thing so
what i do is i make sure that
they do what's called a healthy version
of keto which is high density
nutrient foods especially the trace
minerals and that would be the shellfish
these are high zinc foods tuna
eggs pumpkin seeds lamb
fish as well as selenium is
another important one selenium is
probably one of the most important
trace mineral antioxidants really
important
in the thyroid especially hashimoto's
because you have all this
inflammatory reactions and to counter
all that free radical damage that's
happening with hydrogen peroxide and
so selenium is really important and
where do you get it you get it actually
in fish and seafood
so this is just a chart to show you the
the mercury some people are concerned
about mercury
as long as you have enough selenium
it'll counter the mercury
so like the three types of fish that you
wouldn't want to consume would be
pilot whale which i know i i really love
that
uh mako shark or swordfish
but everything else is is pretty good so
you don't necessarily have to work worry
about that
selenium tuna brazil nuts
eggs sardines halibut
sunflower seeds spinach and beef
shellfish you can see that different
different uh
nutrients contain a lot of different
trace minerals uh so
a well rounded meal would be fine
shellfish i think is is great for aikido
as long as it's a you know
healthy version key additional because
i'm trying to go fast because i can see
the times
running out here key foods i do
recommend a
small amount of dairy for certain people
but if they start getting acne if they
have
problems with fibroids if they have a
prostate problem i'm going to take them
off dairy
um but because i'm from wisconsin
um i like high quality
dairy and of course i do the grass-fed
uh organic
um at halloween we gave out
um these little mini packs and
you know these kids just don't come back
anymore i don't know why
i want to thank you for coming and
listening and have a wonderful afternoon
thank you very much
[Music]